tech companies are under increasing
pressure to address what many insiders
describe as digital addiction research
shows 68 percent of American adults use
Facebook 74 percent of them check the
site every day we reported yesterday on
former high tech industry employees
launching launching a so-called truth
about tech campaigning warning against
constant connectivity the accused
companies like Facebook of fostering
addictive behavior by quote making
deliberate decisions that do great harm
Facebook's head of global safety
Antigone Davis joins us now good morning
tell us about this question of addiction
the charge is that Facebook actively
tries to get people addicted well first
of all there's a lot of misinformation
and miscommunication about the concept
of addiction and how people are engaging
online we really care at Facebook about
making sure that people are engaging in
a positive safe way so you may have seen
recently on Facebook we change the way
your newsfeed works to really encourage
and support interactions with your
family and friends and promote those
meaningful conversations what those
meaningful conversations may draw me in
even deeper I mean those are what I want
to know about and therefore wouldn't
that make me more addictive well again I
think that we know that people are
utilizing these technologies we take
this issue really seriously we've
invested in a research to look at these
issues but we're really trying to
develop ways that our technology is
meaningful and positive for people
so changing newsfeed or recently we
launched messenger kids I don't know how
much you know about that but that's a
video chat app for kids that is actually
just has no ads is parent control
there's really designed to figure out
what people need and to make sure that
we're creating a positive experience we
have done stories about that has
Facebook done its own research into tech
addiction well we've actually just
recently invested a lot of money
investing into into this research and
we've done some research and what we do
find is that people engage in different
ways so I'll give an example
sometimes we see when people are posting
about something that may distress them
that people will actually respond in a
really positive way and provide support
those are the kinds of connections that
we want to ensure that we're helping to
support and create I've been looking at
some of the studies and
one of them that's been cited by the
Association for psychological science
found that nearly half of teens who
spend more than five hours on electronic
devices report feeling lonely planned or
attempted suicide too much screen time
is a bad thing does Facebook agree with
that well you know I think this is
really a question for parents right
every parent knows their child best they
know how much time they think a child
should spend on online and how do you
and how they want them to use those
technologies and what we're trying to do
is really give parents control so for
instance today on Safer Internet Day
which is a day that marks online safety
and being responsible with online
technologies we're launching something
called parent conversations to ensure
that parents have the tools that they
need parent conversations give parents
the latest in academic research the
latest in research from child's
development experts to really give the
tools that they need to make those
decisions wisely but as a parent I don't
want more tools I want to stop having to
dive in front of the phone that my
children can't get away from and do you
worry that that kind of reaction made
shall cause parents to throw the phone
across the room and that's it no more
Facebook no more nothing well I'll give
an example from from my own with my own
child so old is your child she's well
she's now college age so we actually
grew up with these technologies sort of
learning with these technologies so I
really understand as a mom deeply what
it is to not know necessarily how to do
this and where where do I get advice and
which is part of what's behind all this
work but with my daughter when we gave
her her phone she we saw the glow from
her room at night and I really wanted
her to have downtime when she before bed
and so we made a rule we know about an
hour before bed phones down well her
very first thing she said to me was what
you don't do that and so that was a good
lesson for me I had to learn to put my
phone down which we both did we put it
on my nightstand and that Larry went
down now I did go back to check email
before I went to bed but then again I
put it down which was really important
yeah so you're saying do what I do yeah
parents should set their own examples
what you're saying yesterday we had the
people at the table from truth about
tech and they were saying at face book
is really seer
about this they have to really change
their business model do you think that
that's necessary are there any plans for
Facebook to do that well I think two
examples that that that I gave are
looking at how we utilize newsfeed and
figuring out how we promote meaningful
connections is one thing and by the way
we knew when we did that that that was
gonna probably decrease the amount of
time spent on our platform and it did
but that would seem like the right
decision is there evidence that lessness
model is not altruistic I mean Facebook
I think grew up is a way for people to
share and connect it has now become a
way to make money it's an advertising
company I mean Facebook made 40 billion
dollars in advertising you want people
on there as often as possible cuz it
helps you sell more ads well I think
again I think we've made some changes to
ensure if for instance a news feed but I
do think we're really looking to create
positive connections and that meet and
that's a long term business business
model I mean doing what's right for this
is actually in our best is in our best
interest it is in our best interest for
people as well as for the community
people using Facebook for the
connections to be meaningful for people
to see value and we that's what we're
trying to accomplish to connect on that
level well in Taney's so great to have
you here thank you thank you we
appreciate it